right domestic violence harassment some
of the most heinous of crimes crimes
that police officers are trained to
detect and prevent well tonight on this
special Sky News program our serving
metropolitan police officer was able to
use his position of power and authority
to carry out a series of sexual offenses
over two decades
more to the point how were persistent
warning signs in David carrick's
Behavior missed the 48 year old has now
been sacked by the Metropolitan Police
he carried out 49 offenses the number
described by some as unprecedented in
policing history
it's yet another story that raises
profound questions about the way the
police recruit uphold standards and
monitor the behavior and conduct of
their offices our overarching question
therefore tonight is do the police need
policing
we're coming up we'll look at the wider
culture within policing and speak to one
woman who knows only too well what
happens when police abuse their powers
but first let's begin with analysis from
Sky's crime correspondent Martin brunt
so Martin at the center of this is is
one man David Carrick of course and Sky
News has spoken to one of his victims
today aren't we we have a colleague of
ours Andy Hughes has you can imagine
that since yesterday when we got
something about the ordeal that these
victims have suffered at the hands of
David Carrick that all news
organizations have been trying to talk
to some of those victims and you can
imagine that most of them are unwilling
to do so but today one did she's a woman
who lived with Carrick she's now in her
40s and she has described how the man
she fell for her dream man suddenly over
time became evil she spoke to Andy
Hughes I'll tell you what something of
what she said in a minute but she also
shared with us a video that David
Carrick himself filmed around around his
house you can even see him in it briefly
but this is the video
[Applause]
come out to the hallway we've got the
heating for the bathroom floor
into a minor bedroom
hey
[Applause]
clutter everywhere as usual
side the view from our window
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's the corridor
we've got cupboard space outside here
office
round into trim
again clutter everywhere
down the stairs
the kitchen
downstairs bathroom
and the barbecue
in the back Garden
and front room finally
they're getting back up to the back home
foreign
image of David Carrick himself I talk us
through Martin what we've just seen
there what was the context of that well
on the face of it it's a proud homeowner
showing off his house
um we think he filmed it for a friend
who just wanted to see
um where he was living and he goes
around the video
um room by room
um at one point and you only see it very
briefly
um
he's going around the bathroom he goes
around the house one by one but at one
point you see and I think he mentions
the cupboard but you know if you think
about what we now know about that
cupboard according to the police that is
where David Carrick locked some of his
victims we just said there just just
underneath that's it so tiny cupboard
yeah I mean and it is small and one
police officer described it as no bigger
than a dog case
um or dog cage
the point about that and this is where
it gets really chilling he Lots some of
his victims inside there and according
to the police for up to up to 10 hours
um this is his home but it's also the
place where he raped and abused an awful
lot of his victims including the woman
that we've been speaking to
now legally she can't be identified
um because she's the victim of sex abuse
and she's chosen quite rightly
to not to wave her right to anonymity
but what she did do in talking to our
colleague was to give a chilling insight
into her life with Carrick a man she
said that she fell for
here's some of what she said to us
he boasted about his job at the Met he
told me the safest place I can be was
with him at first he was the dream man
he was so Charming but over time that
changed
and this is the change that came over
him he was so evil she said I have no
idea how someone so messed up can be a
police officer never mind give him a gun
if it shot someone I wouldn't have been
surprised
she also said that he boasted of
guarding the queen at Windsor Castle and
Barack Obama and she met his police
colleagues she said when I started to
speak to his friends he would stop me he
didn't want me to talk to anyone a
couple of his colleagues reached out to
me after that a couple have been in
touch since his arrest as well
clearly suggesting in that last comment
that there were colleagues of David
carricks at the Met who were concerned
about her must have had some idea of
what was going on but um as far as we
know nobody blew a whistle nobody
reported him to the met or two of the
other forces that were involved apart
from some of his victims but we know
what happened about those complaints
they weren't acted on until
2021 and these are the most troubling
aspects of this case so let's take you
through the events that led up finally
to the arrest of David Carrick so the 48
year old joined the Metropolitan Police
as Martin was telling us 22 years ago
then while still in his two-year
probationary period Carrick was accused
of harassment and assault against a
former partner he was not arrested by
the met and no further action was taken
then between 2003 and 2009 Carrick raped
multiple women who he abused threatened
with violence and demand
in 2016 Carrick was a suspect in a
Hampshire police investigation following
an allegation of harassment the
investigation was later closed in this
time Carrick continued to rape and
sexually abuse multiple women
in 2017 Carrick was re-vetted six years
late by Metropolitan Police and he
passed
then two years later Hertfordshire
police received a report of assault
between Carrick and a woman during a
domestic incident no further action was
taken then
and in July 2021 a woman reported being
raped by Carrick a year earlier he was
arrested by Hertfordshire police but no
further action was taken once again
and three months later a 50 year old
woman reported that she was raped by
Carrick in September 2020 he was
arrested charged and suspended by the
Met then a further 12 women came forward
well down the street says cases like
carricks are shattering public trust in
the policeman I'm joined Now by Mina
smallman whose daughters were murdered
in 2020 and photographs you may remember
of their bodies were then shared by
metropolitan police officers said hello
there meanest Mormon very good to see
you um the reaction from Downing Street
for number 10 is is shattering and I
think that goes for all of us and I take
it you're you're actually not surprised
by by the story of David Garrett no
sadly no
um this kind of behavior has been
allowed to flourish
in plain sight
and we need to do something about this
rhetoric now from politicians isn't good
enough because we know what the problems
are we need to empower
um samark we need to put legislation in
place where action can be taken
and the thing I want to say is I want
the police officers who Duty it was who
met with him and had to talk to him I
want their names I want them publicized
because they are culpable
we keep on skirting around that issue
but who are these people who are just
saying it's all right mate you're part
of a club keep your nose clean and it
will disappear this is happening time
and time again I want their names I want
to know whose job it was to line manage
him and didn't do their job that's what
I want this is a cultural and structural
problem do you think that is the key to
trying to sort out this mess now you
mentioned Sir Mark Sir Mark Rowley yes
he relatively new commissioner of the
Metropolitan Police September 2022
September last year so he's been in post
nearly four months are you prepared to
give him some time to do that and and do
you believe that that is his project as
well I do I've I've had conversations
with him and I've been very direct and
I've been very clear about what my
expectations are I'm just a mother who
lost two children but it's become bigger
than that it's not now just about my two
daughters it's about every family that
has lost a woman a daughter a child to
acts of violence
it's become my passion as well and so
his hands are tied
the baroness Louise who put the report
out has stated very clearly that the
action and the procedures that should
have been followed when it comes to
um you know disciplinary are not
followed
they're not followed so we've these are
the people that we just know about there
are others that are in the pipeline and
there are others that got through and
they're still serving
there are more they might in the Envy
vetting and uh looking into allegations
against their colleagues but let's talk
about that pipeline you mentioned and
just the scale of the problem so Mark
identifies it over a thousand complaints
and more and serious charges some of
them yeah potentially criminal against
800 yeah serving offices I mean that
that is mind-boggling amongst a force of
what about 35 000. that is just the tip
of the iceberg if you remember and it's
one of those quotes where cressided dick
said
yes rotten apples and I said that
doesn't work and if you want to stick
with that analogy we know what happens
to a rotten piece of fruit in a bowl
that's it contaminates and so the issue
is we need to make everybody accountable
now we need to give powers
to Sir Mark to be able to do what he
wants to do and what he wants to do is
not just address
that kind of middle management
and lower tier that's enabling this kind
of behavior to happen what he wants to
do is actually do some retrospective
work because there's a whole tranche of
police officers that should have been
facing misconduct and they're out and
about they've they've Scot three but
they are perpetrators as well there is a
huge amount of work to do and we have to
call it as it is and I'll say again
I want the name of the police officers
who
it was their duty to take this man off
the streets I want to know their names
they're not invisible people well there
must be quite a few of them because it's
been going on for for 20 years when it
comes exactly Eric I mean there were
there must be many times that he's been
looked at by different offices exactly
and you know this man was an animal a
known animal and what did they do they
gave him a gun
they put him in the firearms and trained
him to use it yeah yeah but what about I
mean 800. how many potential David
carricks are amongst them we need
urgent action I mean there's that fact
it emerged today when somebody's been
interviewed on radio and and television
when he can't guarantee that if a woman
goes in to make a complaint of sexual
assault or something like that that the
officer that she's reporting it to is
not himself under investigation you know
what I'm thinking now to Garner you know
trust again and so that women who are
facing you know they've been raped
they've been attacked that actually they
should be met with a female officer and
no time should a male officer interview
a female on his own and it's the same
kind of thing that we did in schools
when we talked about safeguarding you
wouldn't have a a teacher on their own
with a student in a classroom with a
door shut we're going to have to
implement those kind of things in place
to allow women to feel more confident
and the other issue here is the the
women who are married to police officers
or are partnered with police officers
and are victims of domestic violence
those women are they're told don't
report it and if they do try and report
it they are you know they're told no
leave it with us we'll deal with him
don't worry
there are hundreds more that we that are
too afraid to come forward as well as
those who have come forward how do we
Empower them then I mean do you think
this now is too big a task for the
police to police themselves do we need
an independent body there are
independent bodies that exist but on
this specific issue given how how
worrying widespread and troubling it is
do we need an independent body perhaps
quite often it is another police force
but something entirely different maybe a
women's tribunal or something like that
I think you know there is we need to go
multi-disciplinary
so that
um you know it's not just the police
that are dealing with you know
misconduct that we have people outside
of the police but are trained to be able
to look at
dysfunction within an institution and
also they're trained in disciplinary so
that they can sit on a board because
there's a history of even when it's
disciplinary action it's all in our
in-house it's done by them behind closed
doors and no one has an input that has
to stop and how long has samark got I
mean let's deal with this number 800
officers well don't we want to hear in a
few months and that would be a generous
amount of time that that a proportion of
them have been dealt with either some of
them are facing criminal charges and
certainly they've been suspended and uh
some of them expelled from the force
no how long I jokingly I said
um and I said it to him too I'm giving
you a hundred days I'm giving you a
hundred days to yeah to to do something
spectacular
um
I'd still love to see him do something
spectacular but we need to support him
and we need to remember that another
casualty of of this kind of behavior are
the police officers that are good that
are hard-working they are you know they
are I've got family in the met and they
are they're actually saying I don't know
how much more of this I can do they're
tearing their hair up yeah you know I
think I want to leave the force
uh because I do I want to work for a
force that that operates in this way
please don't go you know I'm I'm
imploring the good ones to stay and we
need to empower
the good ones because the bad ones
they're they're very kind of clique
the abuse that people who speak up
against these people you know it can be
quite covert it could be overt they're
ostracized and they are they can say
goodbye to going up in the ranks
and so we have to kind of reward
the good behavior we have to reward
people who come forward
and we need to out
those um you know senior officers who
actually are making it hard for good
police officers to come forward and
speak about misconduct
it's it's simple we just we just need to
empower those to do that but I think the
turning point will be when we start
getting the names of the people whose
job it was to look at this guy and and
bring him into you know discipline
that's what we need what do you think
should happen to them they should be
disciplined as well well yes they're
culpable
they are culpable they have enabled a
perpetrator to go out and continue to
um abuse women
and that's not good enough and sorry
doesn't even begin to to cover it
and every single family who has lost a
woman or a girl or has been abused by a
male and let down by a police officer
every time a piece of news like this
comes out we are re-traumatized
you know I'm I'm doing this but when I'm
at home and when I heard this news I am
re-traumatized I am living it over again
this is not easy and you know I just
thank God that I've got enough strength
to be able to do this and I do it
because I want it to stop
it has to stop I mean it is also a wider
culture that needs to be addressed and
thinking about the tragedy that befell
your daughters the police officers
involved in that that behavior wasn't in
this category but but nevertheless
expose something very very deep and
troubling within the heart of the
Metropolitan Police a Cavalier a callus
yeah attitude towards victims of the
most terrible crimes I believe this is a
consequence we're seeing the fruits of
the neglect of vetting and also training
you know can you believe that a police
officer can find themselves on the
Streets of London without actually
having had proper training or a proper
interview or had proper vetting
in the police given all those powers and
that that kind of seal of trust
you know the uniform used to be you knew
it was safe
they were the good men and women
and so we're we're letting in these
people who are deliberate
predators
and I think we have a culture where and
I've said it before and I'm not being
light-hearted about it where
perpetrators are saying to other
perpetrators come and join the police
they can't touch us you can do what you
like
I believe that's a real conversation
that is taking place and has taken place
in our police force and so we need to
really get to grips with the rot that's
taken hold of what what was a police
force that was admired well Mina it's
been very good talking to you thank you
very much indeed so many uh good
suggestions and ideas to inform our
subsequent debate thank you very much
thank you for joining us on Sky News
tonight thank you in a smallman there
well of course David Carrick was sacked
as a police officer this morning and
this is some of their action following
the announcement of that dismissal
yesterday was a dark day for British
policing and the Metropolitan Police as
an officer admitted being responsible
for a monstrous campaign of abuse
for anyone who have gone through such
torment is harrowing
but for it to have happened at the hands
of someone they entrusted to keep people
safe is almost Beyond Comprehension I
joined the Home Secretary in making
giving Tribute to The Bravery of the
victims who have come forward but we
have to face up to the further evidence
that this case has brought up of
appalling failures in the police vetting
and misconduct processes this is one of
the most shocking cases the Quran
prosecution service has dealt with
involving a serving police officer
anyone hearing of the 49 counts David
Carrick has pleaded guilty to against 12
victims would agree the sheer magnitude
of his offending is horrifying all I can
say is I'm sorry I'm sorry that we've
let you down and you have my absolute
word we're going to have a ruthless
about sorting this out about getting
these people out the way and creating an
organization that's better at dealing
with the plague of sexual violence that
we see in the country the scale of this
the length of it the fact that he was in
an elite part of the organization where
he's presumably appraised annually he'd
had at least five I think other
complaints about sexual abuse against
him and he was still in post
the reaction after the announcement of
the sacking of David Carrick by the
Metropolitan Police today but he stayed
in post of course despite allegations of
rape for many years that therefore
highlights the huge problems at the
heart of the policing system so how can
change be implemented and rapidly well
I'm joined Now by Palm Sandhu a former
metropolitan police chief superintendent
who says that she faced discrimination
during her time serving as an officer
Susan Hall chair of the London assembly
police and crime committee and back with
us Sky's crime correspondent Martin
brunt a very good evening to you all and
uh Palm Sunday I want to start with you
because I know you listened to that
interview with Mina small and you
yourself have written a book you
mentioned about um the policing and
Prejudice that that you face black and
blue it's called and I put the same
question to you that I put to mean a
small but well it's a reaction you're
not surprised by the case the horrendous
okay case of David Carrick I'm just
really saddened that this keeps
happening we keep getting the apologies
nothing changes and there are solutions
but you've got to be you've got to admit
you've got a problem and not just use
the tried and tested you have to do
something radical to make change happen
and that's what I'm waiting for now well
let's talk let's get into it your
suggestions for Solutions you had me and
a small one there she wants root and
Branch chains but first and foremost she
wants the officers that were
investigating David Carrick over the
many many years the two decades that he
was carrying out his offenses for he she
wants to know who they are and what they
were doing well for me there's two main
main things that I would like to see
happen the first one is that there needs
to be a safe environment for colleagues
to raise concerns concerns about other
people who are in the police service at
the moment that doesn't exist there
needs to be some sort of support network
so that women and men can say this guy
has got a nickname him he earned that
nickname by doing this because you don't
just get a nickname like that you've got
your behavior has got to be
um challengeable but what happens is if
a woman or a man raises issues about a
colleague they are then demonized they
are victimized their div their
promotions development all of it is
affected and unfortunately as a woman
when speaking from experience if you
raise a concern and then you press an
emergency button because you're out on
the street they're going to wait before
they get to you so you're going to get
your head kicked in so you have a choice
between surviving
and just getting on with a job or
actually calling out the behaviors that
that we've seen a parent Susan all let
me get um your input on that specific
issue very important one raised by Palm
Sandy then about how difficult it is so
just how how expensive it may be in
terms of your career to raise concerns
about other offices
well that's right actually it must have
been about six nine months ago I brought
this up with the acting commissioner
before Steve house and asked him if
there could be a a proper whistleblowing
system for staff to tell on others
because we've had other cases as you
well know
um and he said there was no need for
that
um I think I think it's right that uh
that there is a safe space that people
can go to I completely agree with uh
your your other guest farmer
um uh there must be somewhere that it
can be safe because surely people knew
what sort of person he was or they
wouldn't have given him such a nickname
yeah yeah he began with a b word which
what you said before the Watershed
Martin just just in lightness what is
what is the current system then people
know who you are if you raise concerns
about another officer no one on enmity
um no um and I imagine that it becomes
pretty well known within your unit but I
think I think part of the problem is and
palm will know this better than me that
there's a there's a built-in resistance
I think or sorry a built-in reluctance
to inform on colleagues who day-to-day
often have to rely on each other often
in life-threatening positions and I
think it's a big decision uh to
particularly if somebody perhaps the day
before has saved your life or rescued
you from a very dangerous situation to
then take that huge step and go and
complain about whatever bad behavior
they've been up to I think that's part
of the problem so it's a cultural thing
you know these are men and women working
often in a buddy buddy way uh changing
that culture is not going to happen but
let's I mean staying with David Carrick
let's trace it further back because you
know the illness was not necessarily on
his colleagues let's go way back to him
joining the force um Sandy there were
allegations against him before he even
got in it's this vetting procedure it
doesn't seem to be working didn't seem
to be working then it doesn't seem to be
working now well the second solution
that I was going to suggest was that
complaints and vetting is taken away
from the police services so that they
have to have an independent group of
people who look at people properly and
vet them they look at their previous
histories allegations and they join the
dots and what's happening at the moment
is that is not happening they're not
building up a picture about individuals
it's coming in piecemeal and nobody's
adding it together and thinking right
we've had this many allegations is
something wrong and with the vetting
it's a tick box exercise and the onus is
on the individual to fill out the form
and say have you ever been arrested have
you ever done this have you been you
know involved in domestic violence
exercise
that the police have records surely and
if you know but if the test wants to
join them they can look up their own
records but if the checks aren't being
done
um then there's nothing to look at it's
a tick pocket tick box exercise and in
the past there used to be home visits
that doesn't happen anymore and quite
often references are not taken up so
when you join you don't necessarily have
that reference check and then the next
failing was that you're supposed to be
vetted periodically and you're supposed
to be vetted as Susan said when he was
given a gun but he was not re-vetted
properly if he was vetted at all so
that's that's another failing and that's
some another solution that could be put
in Susan all do you go along with that I
mean it it's it's the quality of the
recruits you get isn't it it's the old
adage if you get rubbish and you get
rubbish out
well absolutely I completely uh agree
with palm there we we must have have
that looked into I'm sure Mark Crowley
knows it I mean if nothing else this
vetting system takes forever and a day
as well which is a problem for the force
at the moment uh but it's clearly not
being done properly is that we can all
see that
um
that's got to be changed a completely
agreement part on that but it's all
about speed isn't it and particularly
when we deal with and I was talking
about about this with me in a small one
about the 800 officers serving in the
metropolitan police right now something
like a thousand allegations some of them
very serious indeed against them wow
people are going to say well why are we
hanging around here you shouldn't you
know a proportion of them be be at least
ejected pretty damn quick
well there are so many panels I'll tell
you this there are so many issues with
trying to get rid of bad police officers
this is something Mark Crowley is
working on now and so well Benjamin
swella will absolutely supportive in
that
um the iopc the independent office for
policing conduct takes forever to sort
things out
um so that doesn't help that that gives
a log Jam in the whole system uh that
needs to be looked up we've just
recently done a report on that
um quite frankly more money needs to go
into that so you can get
the ones that really shouldn't be there
back to work and the ones that shouldn't
be police officers out of the police
force so the iopc really does need to be
looked at quite seriously well Mark
Rowley says that's what he's going to do
can he do it Palm Sunday do you think he
can do it and can he do it quickly
enough I think if the will was there it
could be done quickly but I don't think
that the will is actually there really
because I mean he's every pronouncement
so Mark has made seems to be along these
lines but we keep getting apologies this
isn't new there was a report in November
which came from the inspector pointing
out the vetting procedures that they
were failing and there were people who
are predators in the organization
there's Dame Louise Casey's report which
came out in December so it's not this is
this didn't just happen yesterday so
what what are we waiting for is there
going to be another report another
two-year delay it's not quick enough and
with officers
when it takes 18 months to two years to
investigate them they rack up more and
more allegations they can have 10 or 11
allegations before they get to that end
date where they're dealt with that is
not acceptable and this is what's
happening Martin give us your final
thought and I want you I want you to put
this into perspective for us because
this is clearly a huge structural
problem but how threatening is it to the
very fabric of the Metropolitan Police
when you and I started in this business
the big discussion and the and the
cancer at the heart of the Met was
corruption well this is a form of
corruption but it was seen then as as
threatening the very existence of them
is its similar scale or beyond that now
it's very difficult to tell I mean Sir
Robert Mark in the 70s said that his
great wish was to employ to sorry to get
rid of more detectives than he employed
corrupt detectives uh so Paul Condon in
the 90s said that he reckoned there were
250
corrupt officers that he was trying to
get rid of so John Stevens in the early
noughties he indicated that he was
getting on top of rooting out corrupt
officers but they are still there
corrupt in one way or another now Sir
Mark Rowley is talking tough
but at the moment he's in a position of
strength his personal uh position is not
damaged because for the last four months
he's been talking about bad things that
happened before his watch
but he's he's going hammer and tongs at
trying to root out and expose more bad
officers and at some stage they're going
to be exposed they're going to come
through the system there will be
publicity and you know he's not going to
stop all those bad behaving officers but
he'll be judged on how he deals with
them when he does identify them Martin
thank you very much indeed Martin Sandy
Susan Hall thank you all very much
indeed for such an insightful discussion
and you're watching Sky News tonight and
coming up next we'll have the rest of
today's stories including
um the the the latest uh on this
situation